we have to show them the difference you
know in our communities we have to show
them that they can have nice cars they
can get a nice wife they can have you
know uh good clothes or whatever without
selling drugs without wrapping or
without you know being promised uh you
know sports or something like that we
have to show them you know many
different areas and the only way that we
can do this is through mentorship
[Music]
listen i'm still here that's right on
the south side of chicago living in this
tent for 100 days from november the 20th
to february 28th bringing to you the
awareness that you need to know about
the violence in the city of chicago but
also to raise as much money as we
possibly can to build this community
center on this block that is much needed
called o block it's called o block
because it's named after a young man
named od theory who was shot and killed
the gangs kept the o in his name and
kept it as old block we decided we love
the oh we're going to keep it oh but
we're going to call it opportunity block
i'm so grateful and thankful to fox for
giving me this platform to bring to you
ideas opinions thoughts
from rooftop revelations and today i
want to give you part two that's right
part two we have so much to talk about
that we didn't get to get on camera
yesterday and i want to finish it today
as we talk to these two brothers king
randall and travis cochran i want to
talk to you about mentorship and
ownership it's so important that we get
those things going in our community if
we're ever going to revive them and
bring them back to life so king i want
to jump right in uh from our discussion
that we had on yesterday we were talking
about uh mentorship and ownership in
schools but i wanted you to elaborate
more on
mentorship how important is that
especially
to young boys that we're trying to
change their lives absolutely we have to
consider the fact that a lot of our
children only get to see possible from a
lot of more negative influences in their
lives most boys are going to emulate the
men that they are around the most so if
they're around the drug dealers or
watching rappers or whoever comes back
to the neighborhood the most that's who
they're going to emulate so a lot of you
know people who may make it to be
successful etc in these different
communities a lot of them will try and
tell boys you know oh well you shouldn't
be doing this and you shouldn't be that
versus showing them what they can do
versus coming into their lives
consistently because uh consistency is
what breeds the best you know in
children uh it's almost like practice
absolutely if you're practicing
something a lot you'll become good at it
um so we have to show them the
difference you know in our communities
we have to show them that they can have
nice cars they can get a nice wife they
can have you know uh good clothes or
whatever without selling drugs without
rapping or without you know being
promised uh you know sports or something
like that we have to show them you know
many different areas and the only way
that we can do this is through
mentorship and this is what we're doing
at the life preparatory school for boys
in the city of albany and you can follow
us on our website at t-h-e the letter
x-f-o-r-b-o-y-s dot org that's these
footboards.org you know we are we not
only talked about um education and
mentorship
we we
mentioned a little bit about ownership
but i wanted to dig a little deeper
because i really do believe and i've
been talking about it ever since i've
been on this roof that
we have to have some ownership we have
to have some entrepreneurs we have to
start
reclaiming our community and so travis
uh i want you to talk a little bit about
how you feel about the ownership aspect
of what we're talking about i feel like
ownership is very important um it's kind
of like one of those old those old says
you have to take care home first yeah
but you have the old home
so i think even with you been on this on
this roof part of it is they see you're
here taking care of home and this is
yours so even once you build this
community center because god willing
this is going to happen i see this
happening we'll have this center you
have your church and these are protected
areas because they know it's yours and
once you once you can have ownership in
your neighborhoods then you can have
people in your neighborhood to say hey
help this person with this help this
person with this and now let's vote for
these things let's get when we need laws
change and some of these policies that
are coming down that we don't agree with
when you have an owner base you can move
the needle and anytime you have an older
base you could also grow if you have
land if you have a piece of land in this
world you can grow something on it so i
think it's very important that we have
that absolutely you know i've been
talking about the difference between um
um booker t washington w.e.b du bois how
one was about power but the other one
was about development and and what you
all are talking about here is exactly
right up my alley development it's going
to take us developing our communities
rebuilding our communities
bringing new life into our community so
i am grateful and thankful for you young
brothers i uh
see the leadership that's coming up and
that you all are providing for our
community and i'm really encouraged and
inspired that things are going to get
better and things are going to be
different so thank you all for coming
again appreciate it to the south side of
chicago and uh if y'all ever come back
again i got y'all covered hopefully it
won't be as cold
oh my god we're gonna come anyway
whatever we can the whole winter
summer spring you know absolutely and
i'll make sure we make it to albany and
get some people to come to albany so we
can help out with that school man i'm
really i'm really thankful for the
school and i'm really excited about it
and what you're doing with that boarding
school and hopefully a lot of people
from all across america are just as
excited as i am absolutely thank you
all right listen thank you for tuning in
to rooftop revelations it's been a
tremendous blessing talking to these
brothers and allowing you to hear it
again thanks to fox for giving me this
platform i really really really
appreciate it and as i always say until
tomorrow peace